qui
jacques rivette né en 1928 avant de
réaliser paris nous appartient en 1958
signe un court métrage le coup du berger
tout s'est très bien passé en quinze
jours on a tourné comme ça bien
tranquillement et c'est pourquoi on
s'est dit finalement c'est très simple
il fuit on aurait dû passer trois fois
plus de temps et on avait le long
métrage truffaut un jour m'a dit
finalement c'est il faut faire faut
faire comme le coup du berger il faut
partir de la même façon car j'ai dit bah
écoute tu empruntes 80 du franc qui
s'est battu le film à partir du moment
où on fait un montage ce qui prend quand
même du temps imparti au moment où on
paye ont fini par payer les gens qu'on
avait engagé à l'oeil mais on finit par
le payer
ça finit par être un film quand même qui
a je crois coûté 40 millions alors au
départ il a le tournage même en avait
coûté 1 vous sentez un peu responsable
après cette espèce d'engrenages
incroyable dont il n'arrivait pas à
sortir parce qu'il ya eu des arrêts il
avait beaucoup d'acteurs qui ne venaient
plus choses comme ça c'était une
inconscience totale la conscience
absolue à tous les degrés je savais même
pas très bien que j'allais c'était un
peu comme essayer d'éclaircir mes
propres idées et le tournage du film
était un peu une façon d'éclaircir le
scénario le montage une phase en
d'éclaircir de tournage et puis
maintenant effectivement la projection
de moins de public a été également une
façon d'éclaircies apprend central
d'entreprise